Je ne me soucie même plus de nourrir une haute culture
conan thaian maman thaïlandaise lisbonne na
empiler le peu il n'y a pas de colère là-bas
donner une courbe du ventre et
mit e de horizon's l'amazonie tel
droit à ce qu'ils ont dit et c'était la redondance
austin tom trop hostile pour m'avoir
Je le voulais sec et quand je sors la pagaie
à vendre aux enchères, les dentelles du Brésil que nous sommes
selon le dn de soi admis la justice ou
étiquette jude riozinho j'ai utilisé le cercle aldovar
village pour matelas à eau
et là
unibes toujours seulement histoire d'amour twitter
luan avoir un à la fois porto vai
sont venus si vous ne lui avez pas donné l'examen le
examen de point culminant là-bas, elle devait
différent et porte et services dans
et là
une affliction de trou en colère unibes
Igrejado regarde le rythme d'ampiezza youtube
[Musique]
bye juste faire plusieurs liquides viraux
julio race mon frère ours religieux et
c'est certainement je l'ai fait je l'ai enroulé différemment
cérémonie et je croyais que ce n'était pas le cas
déposer des fichiers sur
le stand le nom en portugais est josé
branches de noyer salustiano et dans la nôtre non
ouais appelle jéhovah n'appelle pas c'est le travail un
peu ici dans ce domaine de l'environnement
comment allons-nous fournir quoi du village
et où nous sommes ici à l'entrée ici
d'un sont le d'un parc un parc
médicinal que nous allons maintenant
visiter
c'est un projet le mien est dans le mien
à ma connaissance de
renforcement culturel et nous arrivons
étudier la prise de sucre là-bas à l'intérieur du
nature et vu qu'il faut
les gens sont dans la nature avec
sagesse et nous avons utilisé
façon dont nous avons appris aussi
dans cette connaissance et vient
travailler de cette façon à partir de son là-bas, je
Je pense qu'elle a l'air d'avoir
impuissance à votre goût ou pas
parler un noir seulement au sucre pour nous elle
c'est un vin très sacré qui est très
important pour les indigènes onde na onde
nous voyons des gens se développer
peut se connecter avec la nature
considérait le respect de la nature comme un
être vivant de comprendre que c'est en considérant le
la nature comme notre mère et comme nous
vous voyez ici vous voyez et je pense que
est un pour la population indigène est un
j'ai très sacré très précieux
c'est l'espace que nous avons à l'intérieur
du parc celui-ci est l'un est un arbre
Luan a trouvé le samaúma que les gens qui
des gens pour qui nous avons beaucoup de respect
par l'actionnaire cet arbre qui a un
esprit très fort de la nature et de
nous pour moi pour nous dans la nation elle-même et
lancer le mandala que nous avons
un grand respect de la nature ou
collection spontanée d'instantanés à un
vitesse de route d'élite pendant le sommeil et
l'euro la trouvera giovana rei hi hi hi som
Je donne quand je donne hahaha
tourisme ou citoyenneté l'examen de
tourner à la pluie municipale quand répéter et
junior la nourriture tourne au fil des efforts
de la porte du partage chakana si appétit
quand ils ont résisté et qu'est-ce que Julia a fait de moche
toit que la gratitude est qui déteste c'était
tu veux être un, priez pour que j'en sois un
la princesse assiste a décidé de faire en sorte que
votre autre droit arbre zoo un
alcoolique c'est un avec tuile reçu
sont aigle o ici devait venir en enfer
des affaires comme ça
c'est tellement bonjour tout ce dont j'ai rêvé en premier
remercier dieu comme je veux
payez ceci nous factures ici comme ça
diplôme dans ce câble leadership 10 vôtre
mère étaient présents ici à l'intérieur de la
travail laissé aux femmes et
les hommes qui l'accompagnaient c'est
beaucoup de choses pour nous sont en train de déconner
surtout aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
contradiction remuant ces choses événements
fictif parle moi la terre il faut
partir neuf et à l'abri de currasco mais c'est
un coin doux d'où moi les lettres et
et là
football de fer jusqu'à ce que vous soyez si
difficile mais monsieur chenille juninho
ma grâce de 6 regards d'idée est
compte tenu de la fábio est de 700 hôtels de
homicides dans
et là
le résultat o
João est si tu es tu y vas
son échelle était la sienne l'idée n'est pas de le faire
ce tous les jours pas combien de poissons déjà
ils ont déjà pêché mais ils ne viennent pas aujourd'hui pas aujourd'hui
nous l'avons obtenu sortez de là maintenant ne le démarrez pas
J'étudiais dans la partie à la demande
la femme est responsable de la maison sans elle
dans la partie maison comme dans la partie ménage
de la maison pour s'occuper des enfants est plus
une partie de ma responsabilité aussi
est de prendre plus soin de la partie recherche, non?
chercher dans la forêt de la nourriture pour
les gens à nourrir et aussi dans la partie de
brossé
le temps de ma maison que je fais est
m'occuper de mes enfants nettoyer mon
maison et nettoyer les vases arrêter de boire
de l'eau et c'est ce que je prends
nettoyer autour de ma maison donc non
les ordures et les ordures en plastique sont
depuis que l'autre banane tombe les gens
il joue pendant qu'il chante, il ne mélange pas
tout là-bas donc je balaie avec le
les garçons beaucoup celui-ci je suis venu parler au
Madame, ai-je un nom ou pas ?
appelle ce poêle un poêle en argile et
trop d'ajout c'est pas trop mal comme
ça travaille dur ça ne fait pas que faire du feu
[ __ ] oui là ça marche ça reste ici
l'intérieur n'est pas un
l'alcool si ce n'est pas le téléphone
conduire jusqu'au dernier jour je sais
elle a depuis abandonné l'aviron pour se produire
entre les ferronneries pour dire aimer dormir
pourquoi pas des ateliers au village
la musculation l'a donc tout va bien
Terre
C'est là
et là
être ce qu'il est du trou de la page d'accueil de réglage
minute tu es diamètre sandra forrei
ana avant de prier quelque chose de très gentil
même alors le projet social que le mot
sociale et
bonjour comment allez-vous je suis edilson dans la langue
portugais soldatini achar andava do
les aras, c'est vrai, et je suis professeur ici à
terre indigène il y a 30 ans, alors vous
ça en fait partie intégrante les gens hahahaha et
parler un peu plus de ce type quoi
celui-ci vous pousse vraiment parce que
il y a tellement d'ethnies tellement de sauts il na
amazon oui nous avons bien fait une enquête
pour savoir d'où avez-vous utilisé le venu
de toute façon, qui est le connard
o et en plus de cette recherche j'ai fait
parler avec les anciens, en plein avec les
nos personnes les plus âgées, à droite de notre o
notre peuple est venu de très peu est né de
deux personnes en fait mon grand-père et mon
grand-mère veut faveur napoléon et isabel à l'écoute
qui était ma grand-mère, ces deux personnes qui
J'ai apporté cette graine que j'ai plantée aujourd'hui
nous couvrons déjà près d'un millier
les gens ici dans l'état d'acre donc c'était
cette histoire est très difficile pour nous
les gens achètent parce que notre peuple ara
comme une personne très guerrière qui
nous avions devant tous la lutte de
peuples autochtones, quand il y avait ce
que cette confrontation avec le
Mes blancs, les banques tuées
ici tout faire et toujours utiliser les zones
Je l'apporte devant, puis ils ont perdu leur
la force et la fin de la culture et il en est ressorti
deux personnes pour planter la graine qui
nous avons aujourd'hui
utiliser le ils ont toujours vécu sur cette terre
ils avaient ici je vais au paradis juste ça
il s'y voyait mais à la tête du
frontières droite vivre y vivre avec le
les patrons blancs sortent de là quand il arrive
vu un peu serré dans une situation
même et ils sont venus ici pour le
croisière dans la vallée des neiges un séjour ici
passer du temps ici quand tu étais
même de celui là est sorti et moi au bagé
affluent du Tage, c'est très loin
retirez-vous ici près de la frontière, n'est-ce pas?
beaucoup une question de juste faire ces
voyager plusieurs jours dans la même famille
restez-y et vivez-y un moment
Je reviendrais ici et d'ici je reviendrais
arrête là il a toujours vu ça
dans cette pièce, en transit ici vous
tu ne pourras jamais partir d'ici pour un autre
région et vous êtes très bien ici alors
vivre très bien ou il pourrait être ici dans le
football un jour en ville quand elle
les idées au lasso sont de l'autre côté de l'Amazonie
Non, je ne pense pas, laissez-moi vous dire
voici un peu d'histoire comment c'est arrivé
donc pour la première fois quand il n'y avait pas de terre
indigène quand pas tant que quand
funai est venu, juste que pouvoir marquer ces
terres nous envoyons tout ce que nous pouvons déjà
descendons un peu on a vécu du découpage
seringue à valparaíso une autre ici à
croisière de la vallée un autre bagé juste comme ça
tous dispersés sans terre l'escargot et le
le patron a vraiment aimé aller le jeter dehors
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit il est paresseux et je
comme ça, non ?
et puis avec le temps on a eu un peuple
ici de ma famille est même parti
pour une croisière plusieurs familles
arriver en croisière sans argent sur ce
en rien souffrir passer beaucoup
besoin là-bas à Cruzeiro do Sul na
ville il y avait quand il est apparu ou sur terre
droit indigène qu'il y aurait des terres indigènes
que les Indiens ont des terres et je pars
payer le loyer et vivre dans ce qui était
d'entre eux, c'est qu'ils ont commencé à se joindre, n'est-ce pas?
Funai de venir ici sur le Cruzeiro do Vale
d'être cette réunion était celle-là
parler tout là-bas je les gens vont si
se réunir, d'accord, parce que se réunir juste pour
vous donner un exemple quand nous avons commencé
Ici, dans les années 70, les gens essaient de ne pas t'aimer
mais ici éteindre même l'écoute n'est pas
il n'y a pas longtemps il était un enfant moi
Je pense qu'il est né, non ?
longtemps pas si ce n'est pas 70n pour
aujourd'hui, il touche près d'un millier de personnes, n'est-ce pas?
donc on a beaucoup avancé
grand nous n'avions pas d'éducation n'avions pas
la santé n'avait rien comme je suis allé
fondateur du peuple le plus ancien était
choisi par mon peuple pour enseigner
ici à l'intérieur de la terre indigène mais très
difficile
Je vais vous dire très difficile sans
structure sans savoir sans rien, droit de
travail ou quelque chose que nous
nous sommes confrontés comme ça beaucoup cinq beaucoup
la culture si je te dis ce qu'est la culture
nous ne savions pas ce que c'était que les cultures que je mange
professeur dans un autre mon ami est là-bas
un autre jour était qui nous avons ouvert cet espace
qu'aujourd'hui nous voyons notre chay
peint chanter prendre à pied chanter
ces gants de mer pour moi
pour moi c'est un sons pour moi c'était un
l'espace qu'on nous a laissé
ouvert que nous avons planté qu'aujourd'hui est
porter ses fruits, ici même dans le délai imparti est
ma fille de saint qui l'entoure
confiance profiter de demain je prends ça
est harnaché, c'est le même et mettez-le sur
entreprise je veux boxer je suis plein
le professeur est allé de serra dump marcher le
cycle de visite que sont les généraux qui
c'est la grande chaire de ferreira un aquarium
ambilon de la reine de la fête ou sur terre
[Musique]
quoi
je veux sept mia particuliers là-dedans
secteur je l'ai adoré je pense que la se
réunis et
apprendre à connaître mania da water oil et
Je suis avec toi mon père depuis que j'ai cl12
d'où huesca daliane dix ans pour approcher
ensemble profession sexy ma radio et rock
miley est désigné pour le sang de l'organisme
ledit surfeur potentiel minute chaud
trt-17 où hier le prévisible que
année et quand celui-ci retient le sodium de l'autre
peignage et vin dans
et mettre le compte avec le bon mode de secousse
tournant et saturn roms où sont-ils
signer la sonde ce qui est écrit le
dur sur
et là
C'est là
bonjour je m'appelle regi pour être emanuelle
beatriz comme ça met à jour firjan dans
tous tombant du
l'arrangement immobile où je brunis sinon le
meriti do far minute sertão de
réflexion sur le registraire d'israël
J'ai vu alors sweet eridon dump s'ils sont
Secrétaire israélien pendant Rossi II
et là
et pour mettre le premier juste allé à
entrer lentement dans le sang
l'adorateur de la couleur pour nettoyer le mieux
versets j'ai mis mal l'herbe un coup dans le
vieux sauf le dimanche tu lui demandes
la machine de forage de puits de phoque tibétain est
réparation si controversée
et celui-ci dans le tableau à chasser était
protection pouvez-vous en parler un peu ici est
un tableau que nous peignons c'est nous
allez-vous faire une activité aussi
quelque chose qui représente un
symbole de la nature qui est une peinture
naturel d'est est d'un fruit et dans la récolte
que nos aînés ont beaucoup comme ça
un fruit qui a beaucoup de valeur sert
pour que cette encre aille au xin
faire peur et l'équipe tout est très
important chaque fois que nous utilisons oui
Je sais tout protégé en étant allé à
demain sur l'île de la maison, c'est mauvais
et là
C'est là
le barbecue appelé là et autre chose
gentil avec un
et là
C'est là
Je voulais lui envoyer Jorge Gerdau Sa
[Musique]
et là
C'est là
qu'est-ce que c'est déjà un liquide qui
brûler jarina nous avons un like
il y a de l'eau que nous utilisons pour
la nourriture ainsi que la médecine légère
pour sa main d'insecte aussi toi
veux cette nourriture
c'est très bien d'avoir une morsure de serpent o
son œil lui sert à combattre le
venin de celui ou venin du serpent qui vient
avoir cette connaissance de tous les os
astral qui a survécu dans la forêt
en nourrissant des fruits qui sans
reste avoir un peu de connaissances pour
nous avons l'eau nous avons tout ce qu'il faut
être dépendant du fleuve des plantes
survivre à
C'est là
et là
et c'est une plante médicinale qui
nous l'utilisons pour en adapter un de plus
peu avec la nature avec la forêt et le
les gens viennent à l'intérieur de ça
médecine que nous pouvons adapter
plus avec la nature est de respecter la
la nature en tant qu'être vivant en tant que tel
il y a des êtres dans la biodiversité
il parvient à respecter en tant qu'être humain
et grâce à ce médicament nous
respecter tous les êtres de la nature est
peux-tu voir la nature comme notre mère
et nous faisons ce travail aujourd'hui
peut la médecine un grand respect comme
avec la nature et apprenez à les connaître dans le
notre biodiversité vous pensez
bail et que vous pourrez découvrir plein sud
Après cela, je lui ai coupé la tête pour
guasca c'est ça et c'est comme ça
noix de coco
le pape comprend très bien comment le
peut faire passer cette chose comme si le
esprits à qui parler lorsque vous
à travers cette rencontre il est là et aime
na à travers cette cette force est-ce
connexion avec laquelle nous pouvons nous connecter
nos esprits de nos
ancêtres nous parviennent, par exemple pour
les gens apprendront la médecine il apprendra
les gens restent ici matériellement l'esprit
aller étudier aller voyager dans la forêt inoxydable
ici c'est matériellement mais c'est l'esprit
c'est à l'intérieur de la forêt c'est à l'intérieur d'un
un autre endroit, il apprendra que
prend et que la connaissance que nous avons déjà
est revenu avec cette connaissance
que nous pouvons là dans ce coin et
il est donc très important que ce vin
de la nature qui est vivante
et c'est sacré
et là
C'est là
le meilleur compositeur jusqu'à sept courbes moi
c'est pas prêt ça se termine et tout est mignon un
reçoit le projet dit électricien
pour les cultures indigènes et
et celui-ci a perdu un échelon
rappi luan tu as écouté celui que j'ai
j'ai passé elle est colibri colibri ça
elle a croisé tant de gens et nous restons
liés à la nature que les êtres sont
de c'est bon c'est la forêt tout va bien
Je suis vivant, ça ne marchera pas, je pense que nous
ça reste comme ça là je pense
vraiment il sent le pouvoir et son nouveau
la culture se nourrit enfin de mon
celui-ci l'est aussi
ce qui est portugais est perruche ou flamenco
Qu'est-ce que c'est demain, ne le prends pas
créer est ce que nous voulions
animal de compagnie et
et là
et dans le hall du train j'ai mesuré ici le propriétaire
je vais compagnie et
e-social il est très sérieux les enfants d'être
vole même si je devais qu'il te fasse
alors elle est stupide milligrammes de rue pour moi
il est devant l'option américaine
il est si beau toujours à la fête, n'est-ce pas?
non 10 11 12 13 14 a
puis va coudre ce que tu dois
sérieux ici c'est prendre une douche maintenant et ça
ce sera de faire du tapioca pour le
les gens boivent le matin avec du café oui
oui elle va s'asseoir et je vais verser le
l'eau puis nous faisons du tapioca à partir de gomme et
comment faire du tapioca enfin demain je
Je vais le prendre pour manger là-bas différence ici
ou n'est pas
la déesse non oui 60 moi il homme dans la maison
et le patron est l'homme responsable à la maison
dans la famille et le temps que tu es maintenant à toi il était
pour faire de la farine et j'ai pelé et tiré
mais aujourd'hui, il est rentré chez lui apportera le
la farine c'est toi c'est lui aussi parce que c'est ça
voici la plante cette pomme de terre là elle a
très bien comme ça, quel est le nom de quelqu'un qui aime et
ami et comment la vie est-elle venue avec de na
forêt comme celle-ci ou vivez-vous à l'intérieur
alimenter la fête enfin l'amazone
bonjour bon comment ici oui ah c'est bon un
Dieu nous en préserve et pourquoi est-ce parce que
que personne, non, nous allions tranquillement
vieux ici est plus froid et nous avons
personne non seulement comme l'acheté a le
notre nourriture de nous mata da mata et
maria nous attend poissons et plantes
mangez tôt pour ne pas acheter et vous déjà
Je pensais que je connaissais la vérité c'est pour ça
c'est pourquoi elle est là pas parce que je
Je pense haha ​​​​juste pour une promenade que nous
allez là-bas revenez encore et il y en a
des problèmes de temps en temps pas après tout
non non jamais eu plus maintenant non
il y a plus je ne suis pas arrivé maintenant la farine tombe
se termine à 9h00 je suis toujours sorti de là j'ai déjà
je suis venu là j'en ai tué un j'en ai tué un
Emberbill sérieux c'est quoi cette phrase
et quel est l'animal qui vit dans la maison de
larissa là il épouse là et là à pje o
En cela, le baladeiro ici pour nous de tuer
il y fille tu ne l'as pas je vais passer ou
ne peut pas passer oui oui oui mais seulement ça
il ne m'abaisse pas là et 62 four là et
nous avons fini c'est parti ils ne sont pas là
mesurant là du père là il y est arrivé
avec un fichier dessus là-bas avec moi là-bas c'est tout
le même gars peut monter pour y aller pour avoir le
travailler à l'intérieur de papa sait bien
[Musique]
l'anniversaire hydratant à coiffer
ici regardez celui-ci ici est que le
les gens s'agitent comme ça regarde ici pour sécher
il va faire très chaud alors
comment on fait comment
mettre le feu ici qui est un
faire la comparaison
et qu'est-ce que c'est
C'est là
quel évier passe manquer le manioc oui
puis on le sort d'ici, pierre, on le met
nous à l'intérieur de cela à l'intérieur de cela
sac ici mettre là à l'intérieur de ce sac
puis nous mettons des bâtons dessus
d'ici là-haut la cuisse ici-bas dans le
la côte est d'y sécher à partir de là
artistique d'y jouer vu que c'est pour
remuez pour sécher vous savez cette farine pour
nourriture pour nous à faire pour pour
vendre pour acheter du sel ou du sucre
savon, ces choses, vous savez que nous
la farine vous fait vendre pour acheter
ce zap que nous devons tous à
porto velho porto walter et ici aussi
de toute la mer qui est là-haut passe
ici on lui vend
cravate ici oh bien moche
penser ici et nous lui vendons le
fais tout juste moi mais mes enfants qui
nous l'avons fait, c'est très beau, d'accord, mais pour
même en le recouvrant, nous avons fait les murs
du four, à droite, j'ai mis les planches du
four où l'on met la farine
séchez celui-ci ici, prenez-le de là autant que le
sec edithvale joue ici dedans là
alors jette-le ici, le sac était à moi
frère est le sien puis il y a brûlé après
brûlé et ça y est, ça va sur la clôture pour
créer un jardin où tout est pommes de terre d'ici
que je vais sortir pour que vous voyez merci
papaye très gentille femme papaye
magnifique par ici
Je peux aussi m'attendre à ce que toute la montée soit
le silence tu ne peux pas manger ce n'est pas juste
vous ainsi que la plupart des choses
mal la forêt n'est pas ah ah est peut
pourrait survivre sans rien ne signe pas
l'aide est là ou pas non non je ne sais pas
rien que nous ne pouvons pas nous ne pouvons pas rire non
qui ne meurt pas de faim mais qui doit
plantez-le pour que nous puissions survivre
est sorti de la forêt n'a pas et
assez si vous ne plantez pas
il n'y a pas celle ci on plante ok sinon
déployer et ne pas avoir à venir ici
Vous voyez, il y en a beaucoup ici, non, la papaye
on échange une main la banane le manioc droit
c'est d'ici qu'on fait la farine, d'accord aussi
ici, tu y es déjà allé, tu n'as pas vu
et puis pedro attend là c'est patate toi d'ici
que nous farinerons pierre et de
aboie un ce qu'on appelle donc c'est tout
manioc et
c'est très beau peps c'est nous nous les aras
nous seulement nous n'avons qu'une seule ethnie au brésil
nous existons seulement nous ne sommes pas comme les autres
les ethnies qui, selon hitachi, ne sont pas uniques
il y a d'autres nids qui en ont plus, d'accord, mais
nous non nous il n'y a qu'un seul peuple ara dans le
Le Brésil n'a pas d'autres ni d'autres
savez-vous s'il sortira, il n'y a qu'un seul aras
qu'est-ce qu'on est ici là nous a amené comme ça
d'abord nous étions plus l'ancien était
plus savoir mais d'autres les autres personnes
nous avait mis fin là et non
c'est fini parce que je suis ceux qui sont restés
ils ont couru en voulant te tuer je pense
c'est parce qu'il y avait je pense que c'est parce que non
J'ai aimé les gens de l'Ara, n'est-ce pas?
envie de finir d'être seule avec lui
même droit
c'est pourquoi je le dis comme ça parce que le
ma mère avait l'habitude de me dire tu sais alors
c'est pire que nous comme vous pouvez le voir
à droite, les gens arara parlent le plus dans le
en portugais, juste parce qu'il n'y en a pas beaucoup
les anciens que j'ai vus, c'est vrai, c'était
C'est ce dont je parle
ils sont morts, n'est-ce pas, et ce qui restait du
les personnes âgées qui sont encore en vie
ont un peu honte d'enseigner à
nous savons aussi pourquoi ce n'est pas parce qu'il
Vous pensez que vous n'aimez pas enseigner ?
car aujourd'hui il y a d'abord les
indiens bibbia cais uma, né a cais uma
à base de manioc, leur nourriture
bibiu le matin y passer le passé
le travail arrive à 11 heures juste endurer
avec des lunettes d'ici sur le devant de
manioc billy le matin puis
arrive juste à 11 heures fortes de la même manière
juste une bonne nourriture pour donner ça
manioc qui était sur le quai
et c'est comme ça que nous vivons d'abord tu sais
aujourd'hui on le voit aussi comme ça
la culture est ce qui tient la nôtre
terre notre tradition notre culture
radis buco do chão da un são paulo eu
J'ai bien décidé les gars le culte de napoléon et
intérêt et je ne sais pas si diode pour la création
de chef de la même arrivée au
papier sur
et pendant que vous me parlez un peu monsieur de
quand tu fais des erreurs comme ça plus jeune quand
toi le jeune comme ça ah je ne sais pas 90 ans
il y a comment faire des erreurs dans la vie à quoi ressemblait la vie
et en tant que radio les gens me plaisent
préviens-moi quand tu en as un
et comment prendre la vie là où elle a souffert
univers tu es difficile là expansion
travailler si vous jetez le butin de tomás
Donc, je n'y vivais pas, j'y vivais aussi
vivra ici pour guérir dans le regard
maintenant, fils, ton placement allait
allons-y, nous ne voulions pas aller plus loin
nous allions chez l'autre patron que j'ai fait na
conduire après c'est que nous arrivons à
regarde-moi un peu plus, c'est vrai qu'il est
demander, c'est parce que la culture dès le
notre peuple le boeuf a perdu le droit et pourquoi
beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui ne savent pas
notre discours à nous est pourquoi allez-vous
être né un
le nouveau style m'a appris plus, c'est vrai, mon père m'a appris
arrivé, ton père m'a appelé, je ne l'ai pas raté
Je ne l'ai pas perdu, c'était une femme
repos aujourd'hui ici est lia aller
Même parler portugais ne paie pas plus pour
enlève des sous-vêtements avec une fille c'est pourquoi
perdu si ces gens, beaucoup ont perdu
et c'est maintenant le jour où c'est comme ça, non?
vous savez, non?
oh et pourquoi monsieur parce qu'elle les parents
n'apprend pas à les mettre aujourd'hui je ne sais pas moi
il jure mais il ne parle pas, il ne parle pas
mais il ne dit pas que le peuple avait honte
pour parler de la culture, hein, les plus jeunes
c'est parce que j'ai vu le personnel comme il est dit que
il suffit de le chercher et il y avait
honte et parler de la tournée dans notre
la honte la honte est
g1
bien et parce que tu sais parce que tu as une idée
parce qu'il y a une honte que je ne sais pas
J'étais dans le sang et
et là
et souviens-toi que là tu consommes ton fils
détendez-vous jupiter pour l'idée de la pomme
ressemble déjà à un détecteur de chance de poisson
entendu parler d'eux
d'avoir et d'abdos il sait que ça permet
Le chariot de Celia j'étais stupide
J'ai dit le meilleur que j'avais que les filets se soulèvent
lorsqu'il est dangereux et
le x dis quelque chose les filles que vous êtes
heureux de vivre ici ou pas et pourquoi
très beau parce que c'est bon
et il se peut qu'elle reste dans ce qu'elle
ne joue pas
un sac de se réveiller et de plaisanter se sent si bien
et il y a aussi une ligne qui est bien mais pas
il ne fait pas très chaud de temps en temps non
toi seul vas
salut daiane j'appelle ana luiza oncle radio
suis
oh et toi, j'avais le lit, pas ce mâle
J'étais au bord de la rivière sans électricité
appel croisé par caboco saveur
j'ai appelé je suis aussi moi
appelez heia heia était au bord de la rivière
sans pouvoir traverser j'ai appelé
caboclo caboclo chaman dalla je veux appeler
j'ai appelé j'ai appelé j'ai appelé et j'appellerai arreia
J'étais au bord de la rivière sans électricité
traverser et appeler Pedro caboclo caboclo
J'ai déjà appelé le baby call hey hey pedro
dire que j'ai aussi appelé et j'appellerai
et ai ai ai ai serra ashanti s'unissent ici à
lune que de copier combien je dors
C'est moi qui ai dit que ce n'était pas ça
et là
salut et qu'est-ce que c'est parce que les gens
toujours le football qu'il serait il non
fait une erreur est le meilleur avenir possible pour tante
Salu est-ce le meilleur avenir qui
les gens verront que de notre héritage que
celui que ma grand-mère a quitté pour aller à celui-ci
les gens appellent dalla qui est ton secours
culturel vos mythes qui est où nous
ça pourra être, c'est une graine qui
elle l'a laissé ici aujourd'hui est en train de germer
pour que les générations futures sachent
une partie de ce travail que je ne peux pas
terminer puis-je continuer alors c'est un
travail très important pour l'avenir
génération fait partie de la sécurité de
notre terre est notre identité culturelle
et ils ont aussi fait celui-ci
connaissance de ce travail
le bébé aussi et enfin c'est
même sens d'intervalle dès que le
vraiment dans la mère en tant qu'être humain
être vivant ou une chose une image un
petit
oh va te faire [ __ ] c'est vraiment dans l'autre
le truc c'est qu'on l'appelle comme mère comme la
simple respect de la considération à l'intérieur
de ce qui existe en elle, c'est que le
on voit que seule une mère prend bien soin d'un
fils de cette façon est par exemple nous
nous avons ici la nature de
forêt et nous allons par exemple
donc il n'y a pas d'arbres ici si
donner un veto ou qui est au milieu, d'accord?
la forêt attrape d'abord dans la forêt un
la forêt est déjà venue ici, fais attention là-bas
quand j'arrive nous y sommes déjà
d'abord et la forêt combat ensuite le
les gens c'est parce que de l'eau que nous avons
de la nature des plantes pour arroser la rivière à
la nourriture donc il n'y a aucun moyen de
les gens ne le considèrent pas comme un
mère où est tout ce qu'il y a pour que nous allions
le jackson être le concessionnaire des villages le
le redémarrage du club xau offense la blague
embrasse un son puis fais un son prends le avec
voyant recevoir ajouté il m'appelle da
wow était nu de cette culture sécurisée est
heureusement baise oncle rui a
salut salut salut la course a a a a
le poêle série b
C'est là
et puis les indiens chantant rappelant le
petite amie sait avoir une petite amie
il chante en disant à propos de copines que
utilisé pour dîner là-bas hein
salut et le matin matin matin mer et demain
va demain voir les ordures qu'il est tombé sur le visage
coco la soeur yo queiro hirohito chuio va
soeur ar o cuiabá ce n'était pas moi et la mère
mère aime c'est mauvais et voiture et voiture
rejeter et diffuser le pouvoir du collier de ma chère soeur
et demain demain demain demain demain
demain demain demain demain demain mon
sœur
l'argent qui va soeur qui le porte
produit j'aime entendre la wii u rayman
et demain demain demain demain demain maman
c'est mal là pour présenter un papa j'y vais
sortir n'est pas